bienvenue dans cette seconde partie non
prévu à la base mais qui je pense
nécessaire pour la digestion
je rappelle que c'est une vidéo 100%
subjective et que tout ce que je raconte
n'engage que moi et ma parole
en espérant qu'elle vous plaisent alors
n'hésite pas à lâcher ton plus gros
pouce bleus attention spoil évidemment
on parle du futur des héros suite aux
évènements de endgame donc voilà bref on
y va
bruce banner comme nous l'avons vu
boehner a enfin fusionner avec hulk pour
créer une parfaite harmonie alliés en
l'intelligence et la puissance nous
sommes presque face à un nouveau
personnage et qui prend beaucoup de
place dans une game
néanmoins dans la politique du film les
vieux avengers laissent leur place à du
sang neuf laner ne semblait même plus
intéressé à revenir en tant qu à wenger
ce début d'année games et surtout ne se
bat plus comme hulk pour elle faire
l'époque du hulk en colère et déchaîné
est révolu klose aussi très importante
concernant banner c'est qu'il a effectué
le snap permettant de ramener tout le
monde et y aller c'est la quasi totalité
de son bras tout comme thanos à la fin
d'une infiniti war lusage du bras de
banner va être grandement réduit
handicap ans pour un personnage aussi
puissant cependant bonheur restera
certainement encore actif pour les
nouveaux héros nous sommes sur un
personnage qui a encore du potentiel et
des choses à nous proposer
mais je pense réellement que la perte de
natacha la mort de toni la retraite de
steve et l'absence prochaine de thor
risque d'isoler grandement le
scientifique docteur strange stéphane
sereine je vais être l'un des héros les
plus importants un des plus puissants et
qui va énormément se développer ce
dernier va certainement se remettre en
question par rapport à la pire du temps
malgré la victoire contre thanos et le
retour des 50% d'êtres vivants de
l'univers strange a techniquement failli
à sa mission qui était de protéger la
pire du temps est ce dû à sa défaite
face à la noce dans infinity ward où il
n'avait pas d'autre choix que de la
donner nous savons que le héros va
continuer son origin story en 2020
doctor strange 2 il continuera de
protéger l'héritage des sorciers ainsi
que la terre face à ces nouveaux ennemis
bordeaux sera très certainement de
retour mais étant donné que strange ne
possède plus la pierre du temps et donc
cela veut dire qu'il ne peut plus
manipuler le temps justement est-ce que
bordeaux sera toujours aussi réticents
quand alors revoir et ne pas le punir
pour ces pseudos péché et bien si nous
suivons les comics oui il sera toujours
son ennemi donc à voir ce que fera le mc
eu avec ce personnage nightmare est
fortement soupçonné pour être le
prochain vilain de doctor strange et
amènera avec lui notamment la dimension
cauchemar je dois dire que dans une
phase iv plutôt censé être cosmique avec
une arrivée de probablement le
multiverse ainsi que d'autres dimensions
ce serait très intéressant et cela
ferait sens strange apprendrait à
manipuler les dimensions chose que l'on
n'a pas encore vu à l'écran et qui
ferait un beau grain le personnage je
garde toujours en tête comme je vous
l'affirmé dans mon vieux trois théories
sur doctor strange l'arrivée de clea
dans le mcs soit le véritable amour de
strange dans les comics mais également
la nièce dormammu lui même reste in
palmer était pour moi bien pour le
premier film de doctor strange quand il
n'était encore qu'un simple docteur mais
à l'heure actuelle un gouffre s'est
creusé entre les deux personnages et
n'ont plus rien à voir l'un avec l'autre
mon héros préférés encore du chemin à
parcourir et comme l'affirment l'ancien
dans endgame il est censé être le
meilleur des sorciers suprême il va
clairement devenir une icône est l'un
des avengers les plus puissants du mc eu
bref j'ai ultra at faucon
faucon est clairement la grosse surprise
de ce film même si c'était prévisible un
jour ou l'autre je vous l'avons c'est
comme si il venait de se faire pistonner
et avait pris jour 1 million d'abonnés
d'un coup bon j'admets que l'image en
fait n'est pas folle mais vous comprenez
l'idée effectivement suite à la
délégation du rôle de captain america à
sam le personnage vient de se faire
propulser au devant de la scène
faut qu'on va prendre ce rôle très à
coeur même un peu trop je pense et se
fera très certainement formé par bucky
et peut être même notre vieux steve lui
même j'espère sincèrement qu'il fédérera
les nouveaux avengers
malgré le manque de lien entre eux et sa
jeunesse qui pourrait s'apparenter à un
manque d'expérience concrète
il est clair qu'on est loin d'avoir fini
d'entendre parler de faucon nous sommes
clairement dans une nouvelle ère soit
proche du début de la phase 4
je suis réellement curieux de voir ce
que ça va donner de qui barnes il est
clair que bucky ne sera pas vraiment au
devant de la scène il ne l'a jamais été
et même après une game je pense le
personnage un passif beaucoup trop
sombre pour rester découvert à la vue de
tous je pense également que le
personnage va commencer tout doucement à
vouloir arriver à son terme comme le
fils steve son grand copain de toujours
et maintenant vieux et ne sera plus
présent pour l'épauler néanmoins deux
qui auraient pu demander à retourner
dans le passé comme steve mais ne l'a
pas fait donc c'est que barnes l'a
choisi de lui-même
d'ailleurs il a aucune raison spéciale
de retourner dans le passé soit dit en
passant
cela veut donc dire qu'il a encore des
choses à nous montrer et à nous prouver
faut qu'on a besoin d'un mentor de
quelqu'un sur qui s'appuyer pour
apprendre et avancer il est encore tout
jeune depuis civil war ça m'a prouvé à
bucky qu'il était clairement un allié et
ses forces et qu'ils resteront proches
après une game comme deux vagabonds but
qui restera pour former sam et l'aider à
faire le bien
à voir ce que ça peut donner mais ça
semble prometteur
thor et les gardiens de la galaxie nous
allons clairement faire face à une toute
nouvelle facette des gardiens de la
galaxie
j'en suis certain les gardiens sont
techniquement le seul groupe dayraut
encore réunies et actif contrairement
aux autres qui ont perdu tony natacha et
captain puis d'or les a même rejoint
déjà rien qu'avec endgame on peut très
facilement deviner l'intriguent du
troisième film des gardiens
effectivement la gamme aura du présent
même si ce n'est pas montré dans la game
est morte car thanos a détruit les
pierres dont celle de l'âme ou gamme
aura était à l'intérieur il ya
énormément de choses à dire sur eux et
je pense sincèrement qu'ils vont évoluer
et prendre une place considérable dans
le mc eu c'est donc la gamme aura du
passé qui à la base était aux côtés de
thanos qui a décidé de le trahir
grâce à des bulles à certains pensent
que cette dernière a disparu du au
claquement de doigts de tony qui a fait
disparaître thanos ainsi que son armée
mais je ne pense pas camorra est trop
importante dans les gardiens de la
galaxie pour la faire disparaître comme
ça sans rien dire et justement kw il
semble à rechercher avec son radar à la
fin du film avant que thor ne les
rejoigne il va falloir tout recommencer
avec gamme aura hélas reconquérir du
côté de queen
les gardiens vont très certainement se
mettre à sa recherche pour la faire
revenir dans le groupe
néanmoins n'oubliez pas un facteur très
important de ce troisième film l'arrivée
tant attendue dadame warlock ce
protagoniste est très important dans les
comics est très puissant grossièrement
par alan c'est une sorte de vision
puissance dix mille cependant il aura un
rôle très différent des comics étant
donné qu'il affronte thanos normalement
et tient même le gant avec les pierres
chose qui vient de se conclure avec
endgame la particularité dada morlock et
qu'il est neutre
il n'est pas un gentil mais ce n'est pas
non plus un méchant il se peut donc que
le mc eu en face un méchant très sérieux
et cela expliquerait pour moi la venue
de thor dans le groupe
ismet en veut au gardien suite aux
évènements de l'opus 2 des gardiens adam
sera donc l'ennemi des gardiens mais ces
derniers ont un problème ils sont un
groupe fusionnel mais
manque en termes de puissance désolé il
faut l'admettre tort semble avoir trouvé
sa voie après avoir échangé avec sa mère
dans le passé l'ex roi d'asgard d'
délègue le rôle de chef à walkyrie et va
partir à l'aventuré vagabonder en
compagnie des gardiens
torre a encore beaucoup de choses à
prouver et nous continuerons de suivre
ces péripéties je pense qu'il est
réellement là pour occire vo c'est le
niveau des gardiens en termes de
puissance ce dernier s'est lié d'amitié
avec le groupe et je pense qu'il ne sera
pas de trop pour faire face à d'hamoir
loc
en tout cas j'ai vraiment très très hâte
de voir ce que ça va donner ça va être
ou war machine
que dire sur war machine je vous avoue
que c'est un héros qui reste quand même
assez secondaire et je vous avoue que
c'est compliqué et d'essayer d'imaginer
son futur james rhodes est un vieux de
la vieille il est présent depuis les
débuts d'iron man et était très liée aux
premiers à wenger malheureusement son
plus grand acolytes au niger nous
quitter captain prend sa retraite
natacha nous a également quitté hawk eye
va certainement aussi prendre sa
retraite d'avengers également ainsi que
banner wawatie j'imaginais dire ça un
jour ah oui et tu auras est partie
vagabonder du coup bref war machine ne
possède plus de réel coéquipiers suite à
une game et je pense que cela va signer
probablement son arrêt le personnage eu
un grave accident lors des événements de
civil war
il est possible que ce dernier souhaite
se poser personnellement je vois bien
comme un mentor des nouveaux avengers et
rester vivre dans le qg d'ailleurs ce
dernier pourrait apporter son savoir et
son aide au développement d'une nouvelle
cohésion de groupe qui devra se crée au
fil des années tout comme béquille il
pourrait même et des faucons à se
développer un rôle bien amoindri mais
qui ferait sens captain marvel
carole à l'heure actuelle est l'un des
héros que je préfère le plus dans le mc
eu je trouve le personnage très
intéressant et très différent des autres
il est clair que carole ne se prend pas
pour n'importe qui elle a conscience de
sa puissance et le fait savoir dans une
gaine il est même quasiment sûr que
carroll n'a dû subir aucune défaite
depuis les années 90
je vous avoue que je me demande encore
si le rue jean story de captain marvel
se continuera dans les années 90 où à la
suite dun game mais je pencherai plus
sur une suite poste endgame obligé
carole va prendre le temps de retrouver
fiori et profiter de son retour elle
semble ne pas l'avoir vu depuis son
premier film
ce serait dingue de retrouver aussi une
mariée rambo sa collègue de toujours
aujourd'hui bien vieilli meilleur la
petite fille de cette dernière aura
grandi depuis et sera une adulte affirmé
il y aura forcément de retrouvailles
commente man avec cassis s'il n'est pas
mort dans les trente dernières années il
est fort c'est que nous reverrons à l'os
pour épauler carole dans ses aventures
liées aux cris et aux skrulls
mais je vous avoue que j'ai de grosses
attentes concernant carolle il est clair
qu'elle se sent vraiment puissante elle
se sent comme la police de l'univers
mais je pense qu'elle subira de
sérieuses difficultés dans son second
film et et devra apprendre qu'elle ne
peut s'occuper de tout le monde
à force de vouloir faire la loi
elle-même et rendre justice elle-même
carole va se mettre des gens à dos et
devra redescendre dans son estime
je pense déjà que la claque que tanoh su
ami avec la pierre du pouvoir dans
l'aisne games va la faire réfléchir
quant à sa condition de super héroïne
elle a dû comprendre qu'elle n'était pas
si invincible que ça et son ego a dû
chuter
néanmoins nous sommes très loin de
savoir ce qu'il s'est passé entre son
premier film et endgame et ceci perturbe
beaucoup qu'a vécu carroll quelles ont
été ses expériences qu'est-ce qu'il l'a
forgé j'espère vraiment le savoir un
jour ou l'autre
en tout cas comme l'a souligné toni dans
endgame elle fait partie du sang neuf
des avengers et a eu le temps de se lier
à eux suite aux cinq années post
infinity ward
elle sera présente pour la terre et
notamment fiori qu'il ne l'a appelé
qu'une fois en 30 ans
enfin voilà cette seconde partie
s'achève et j'espère qu'elle vous aura
plu j'ai énormément d'idées concernant
endgame mais j'ai besoin de vous
qu'aimeriez vous voir ou savoir ou
encore théoriser sur ngame de quoi
voulez vous que je parle pour les
prochaines vidéos
je vous laisse arbitre du futur de la
chaîne en tout cas la chaîne grandit de
jour en jour et je tenais réellement à
vous remercier du fond du coeur car
c'est grâce à vous vous connaissez la
chanson je vous invite à vous abonner à
laisser votre plus gros pouce bleus est
d'ailleurs le concours que je fais sur
twitter est actif jusqu'au 8 mai donc
foncé aller c'était argot rock et que le
liner ce soit avec vous
[Musique]